sobrevivió al genocidio tutsi en 1994
sus dos hermanos fueron asesinados en
este barrio de la capital ruandesa
estaban matando a la gente aquí donde yo
estoy había cadáveres por todas partes y
los tiraban en la cuneta o en una fosa
común los habitantes del barrio de
mujima siguen viviendo a la sombra de
este edificio construido por Félix
siembra acusado por la justicia
internacional de financiar las masacres
en aquella época epafrodita vivía cerca
del edificio escapó de las milicias
futus que masacraron a los tutsis tras
el genocidio se unió a ibuka una
organización de supervivientes apoyada
por el gobierno
ese edificio de ahí era la casa de feliz
y en cabuga albergaba una base del
Antiguo partido en el poder el mrmd los
milicianos del barrio venían a sus
armas aquí venían del Norte del país
salieron de la casa cuando se les ordenó
ir a matar
tras más de 20 años huida feliz la
tortuga fue detenido en Francia en 2020
un tribunal especializado le acusa
también de financiar radio de milkolín
que alentaba la masacre
había muchos mensajes que decían que los
tutsi son enemigos del país que hay que
matarlos así se convenció a muchos
extremistas de que había que matar
extremistas
por su responsabilidades en los medios
de comunicación extremistas kabuga será
juzgado por incitación a cometer
genocidio Ruanda emitió más de 40
órdenes de detención internacional
contra presuntos genocidas residentes en
Francia Todavía están pendientes según
las autoridades holandesas para las que
el juicio de filicianka buga es un
asunto urgente El tiempo pasa y la gente
envejece los organizadores murieron y no
nos enteramos hasta 10 o 15 años después
y nunca fueron a juicio Eso es malo para
la historia del país y para las víctimas
ya se ha declarado No culpable sus
abogados han pedido que se suspenda el
juicio debido a su mal estado de salud